with news that we might be getting the
massively underrated Farscape series
back I have to ask the question what
other massively underrated sci-fi shows
were there and what are my top three
welcome to Sidra your SciFi TV and Movie
Channel say top three it's actually
going to be top four but I'm going to
lump two of them together so let's
pretend it's a top three but what is
first on my list Lex it ran from 199 7
to 2002 and it is one of the very rarest
of things a TV show produced in
cooperation between Canada and
Germany can you imagine what those two
cultures would produce well they
produced a TV show called Lex and it was
as mental as you'd imagine I cannot
really tell you what this show is about
even though I watched it religiously for
five years I remember the guy with the
black hair and he had the thing and it
like oh he was um like he was living
dead or something and I kind of remember
that the spaceship was a giant bug and
it used to like have like death Rays I
think that was the Le I think it was the
ship that was The Lex if I remember
right and I genuinely remember being
fascinated and completely confused by
every single episode when this show was
released critics actually said that this
was for people that liked Babylon 5 but
wanted to be a little less cerebral I
actually think though you really needed
to concentrate watching Lex because it
really threw a lot of different concepts
at you I actually think it was massively
underrated partly because people didn't
really understand what was going on but
it was one of those shows that you could
analyze and you could think about and
that you could go into the pub the next
day with your mates and have a couple of
pints and just go what the freaking hell
was that about and it would trigger
Lively debate it was exciting it was
gory at times it was violent it was
pretty low budget but they got every
dollar on the screen and it did bravely
push
boundaries as I said no clue what was
happening but it was fascinating to
watch and yeah most definitely
underrated number two on my list is a
show that was underrated because
basically the person that kind of
co-created it William
Shatner I actually remember when this
came out and it was sort of a joke that
he'd written a bunch of novels and that
um even though that there was a ghost
writer involved as well it was sort of
what's William Shatner doing right a
novels and the show sort of really only
existed because William Shatner was
involved and obviously big
star the series concept though was
genius there was sort of this like
cybernetic digital drug that created
sort of like a simulated reality a
matrix kind of thing for anyone to took
it early in things it was massively
addictive and triggered loads and loads
of crimes um and actually caused
significant brain damage for a lot of
users in the early versions of the drug
in the couple of first Seasons um but
this was a show that did get five
seasons and like four or five TV movies
all based on the nine novels that
William Shatner and his co-writer did
produce the show though was clever and I
honestly think it was inspirational for
a lot of shows that followed it I'm
thinking shows like Fringe which did
have a similar feel to a lot of the
plots I also think you
know the movie The Matrix it does feel
like the wowski brothers maybe saw Tech
Wars I actually think this is one of
those shows that was maybe a little bit
ahead of its time and if it had come
along just a couple of years later when
social media was really starting to kick
off then I think it might have actually
captured the imagination a little bit
more I actually think it was possibly
because it was just a couple of years to
soon it went over a lot of people's
heads a little bit they didn't realize
the danger of the digital world so
weren't maybe afraid of the
possibilities the show was Raising
because we hadn't got into the digital
age quite yet it was a brilliantly
interesting show I loved it mainly
because William Shatner was in it I'll
be honest he was the main reason why I
started watching Boston Legal because I
just saw William Shatner was in it and I
just thought well I'm watching that and
actually Danny Crane in that is just his
best character by a million miles and if
you've never watched Boston Legal why
not William Shatner and James spad are
in it what else have I got to say number
one on my list is a twofer but for a
very good reason Andromeda an Earth
final Conflict now Andromeda starred
Kevin saber a man who I follow on
Twitter or exor or whatever hell is
called and he's
colorful is a
very colorful conservative let's say and
he has some opinions on the world and
politics that I do wholeheartedly
disagree with but as actor I always
really liked him I thought Hercules was
brilliant and I started watching
Andromeda because he was in it we had
Lexa do or Lexa do however you'd say her
name doig how am I supposed to say that
who actually then married Michael Shanks
AR own Daniel Jackson and then appeared
in Stargate as
well so this show really did have
everything an in an insanely beautiful
woman who I was massively in love with
and Michael Shanks you lucky bucker the
series though is being thrown together
with a final Conflict because both of
these shows were dreamed up at least
originally by Jean
Rodenburg producer for Earth final
Conflict and now I'm not going to talk
about that so much because of one very
good reason I didn't like it it was a
bit like V the way it started this alien
race came down pretended to be our
friends but really wasn't it meandered
though and in the fifth season it
completely forgot about that original
race and went with this completely
different race that was like openly
violent against us I don't know if
Executives over at the channel basically
said you know you need to do something
different we're losing viewers so they
just went ah screw it let's just do
something crazy but it really didn't fit
with the rest of the series um they also
had a problem with the cast they turned
over loads they had loads of different
cast members and it was just a very
difficult show to follow um but the
actual Concepts were really fascinating
it was well written and it was an
interesting show but Andromeda now
Andromeda was a good show it had some
really brilliant Concepts in there for
one the Andromeda was a very powerful
Starship
and I loved how they had the drones that
used to walk around repairing the ship
all the time that was the first time I'd
ever really seen that in a Sci-Fi series
and something that's been copied since
something that was thought up by Jean
rodeny all those years
before the show came out at a time where
we didn't really have any Star Trek or
anything other the like big sci-fi shows
so it sort of filled my need for it was
a show that had some really interesting
ideas but was was basically quite simple
it was a Star Trek type show where
there's a ship there's an
enemy do fight fight fight and crack on
it was just one of those shows that okay
wasn't massively complicated but was
just
wellmade and ah it ended too soon for me
I do think the later Seasons lost a bit
of their Mojo they didn't really know
where they were going they didn't never
really had a decent villain and that was
the biggest problem with the series
really the villain was kind of
forgettable and I to be honest I can't
tell you a single one of them so um I
could I'd have to Google them to even
tell you what any of them were so that
was why the show never really got
catapulted into greatness but it is a
show that was beautifully made had great
characters had really interesting action
sequences Etc and was just a show that
deserved a little bit more attention
and maybe if it had got that at the time
it could have pushed on and become a
really great Sci-Fi series it deserved
that little bit more and that's why it's
going to be the top of my list as the
most underrated of the sci-fi shows
because it was almost
brilliant but guys get into the comments
and tell me what other sci-fi shows that
you think over the years have been
massively underrated there have been a
few and I'm actually just going to throw
in one one other
show the kill Joys that was also on
sci-fi that was another show that really
deserved more than it got but what shows
do you want to add to the list get into
the comments and tell me if you are new
to the Channel please don't forget to
like subscribe if that Bell notification
because it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com cidra
which is where most of our videos
Premiere first and you get to see them
without the adverts also you can go to
c.co UK which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on most of
our videos and we try to add a little
bit more information for you to digest
go and check it out as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next
[Music]
time